The first one simplifies to negative 4 times the square root of 2, and the
second one simplifies to 27 times the cube root of 3. Nice work if you got both
of these correct. Simplifying roots isn't always the easiest, so let's see how
we can do it. We can split up the root of 8 into the root of 4 times 2. We can
also split up the root of 50 into the root of 25 times 2, and the root of 200
into the root of 100 times 2. This gives us perfect squares, which allows us to
take square roots in our next line. Now that we're here, we can take the square
root of 4, which equals 2, the square root of 25, which equals 5, and the
square root of 100 which equals 10. We multiply the numbers in front of our
radicals, to get 6 root 2, minus 30 root 2, plus 20 root 2. This leaves us with
6 minus 30 plus 20 times the square root of 2. When we subtract and add these
numbers together, we'll get negative 4 times the square root of 2, our final
answer. For our second problem we want to break up these two numbers into
perfect cubes. I know 81 is the same thing as 9 times 9 which is the same thing
as 3 times 3, times 3, times 3. I rewrite 81 using 3 cubed times 3. We do this
since we know if we have a factor that appears three times we can take it
outside of the cubed root. So I used my product rule to split up this radical
into two pieces, and then we take the cube root of 3 cubed, which just equals
3. For our second radical, we split it up into the cube root of 8, times the
cube root of 3. Notice that I've rewritten 8 as 2 to the 3rd power. We do this
so that we can take the cube root of 2 cubed, which gives us 2. We multiply 7
times 3, to get 21, and we multiply 3 times 2 to get 6. Now we have two
radicals that have a matching index and a matching radicand. So this means we
can add them together. We'll have 27 times the cube root of three.